what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are here with Planet Hulk World breaker
the return of the world breaker hook and
what this does is it kind of gives us a
storyline that involves the Incredible
Hulk a thousand years in the future it's
really really cool right it's an
alternate reality story but it's really
really cool now there are going to be
some big differences and some holes we
need to fill as far as Planet Hulk and
how all this transpired and of course
we'll cover that as we go through this
but what it does is it initially picks
up with what's called The High Priestess
so of course with this being a thousand
years in the future the planet of the
car does not exist the way that it used
to and for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this when the Incredible
Hulk originally landed on sakhar it was
led by a guy called the Red King who was
really just a terrible person but of
course the Incredible Hulk basically
overthrew his entire Kingdom and then
became a kind of peaceful ruler of
Planet Hulk until everything went
sideways and his family died and then he
came back to Earth during World War Hulk
and went to war with the Illuminati but
what this does is it establishes or
seems to point to this idea that in the
absence of the Hulk that Society
followed the best possible path it could
have insofar as trying to find a way to
govern itself now there was a lot going
on behind the scenes and we'll talk
about that but one of the things that's
established here is that the current
people or the citizens of sakhar hate
what are referred to as the heart that's
basically another name for hulks it's
what they call them here and again we'll
fill this stuff in but what it does here
is it initially picks up with a couple
of what look like hulks who are here on
this world and in turn they're literally
just kind of fleeing for their lives as
best they can that the different people
out there that have gamma radiation that
are by all standards the measurement
hulks are basically being tracked down
they're being hunted now what you also
have here is what's called like kind of
a floating city that just exists out
there they don't really know a whole lot
about it we'll find out about that as
time goes on but what ends up happening
is that these two teenagers basically
these two young people are tracked down
and attacked and of course that's kind
of the establishment that anybody
related to the Hawks are tracked down
and either killed captured or any one of
those now the younger boy is ultimately
captured here and the girl ends up
taking off but as she makes her way she
ends up coming across another person
who's infected with gamma radiation only
for us to find out that it's actually
Amadeus Cho that it is it is the Amadeus
Cho now here's the crazy thing about
this right how in the world did Amadeus
Cho get from Earth onto sakhar during
Planet Hulk all of that will make sense
right we'll make sense out of all this
stuff but one of the things that happens
is that she presents herself as
basically his granddaughter right like
literally like you are my granddad
we are related and kind of going forward
from there we don't immediately learn
her name but what they also talk about
is the nature of the green scar right
the eye of anger the world breaker Hulk
now Hulk is still around Banner is still
around in this place but the reality is
he's just kind of hidden he's away he's
removed from everything and no one
readily knows where he is but on Amadeus
Cho is very very kind of uh Coy right
he's not very forthcoming with
information in terms of how all this
happened everything that took place the
collapse of the world why hoax are being
hunted all that kind of stuff the only
thing that's really going on here is
that this girl's brother was basically
stolen right like the grandson of
Amadeus Cho if you want to call him that
and so what they end up doing is
basically going on the hunt for Bruce
Banner right to find banner and to find
World breaker and to basically go
forward from there now the other thing
they have here is there's kind of like a
little bot that Amadeus Cho had created
somewhere along the line that is able to
kind of move around and is able to
broadcast a video image but it's more
watching and it's not really you know
conversing they can't talk back and
forth now for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with Amadeus Cho he was
created by Greg pack in the Incredible
Hulk Mythos and the idea behind Cho is
that he is this guy who's like one of
the top eight smartest people in the
world his power if you want to call it
that is he can basically analyze any and
all variables in any situation and
figure out the best possible way to
ensure that situation works in his favor
so he's similar to Domino in the sense
that Domino from the X-Men can bend luck
in her favor the difference is that
Amadeus Cho uses his intelligence to do
that the kicker about all this is that
he's exceedingly old here right he's
centuries old and so as a result of that
his mental faculties aren't necessarily
what they used to be more so than that
because of the fact that you have them
on the lamb right they're literally on
the Run they're ultimately discovered by
a sentinel that's operated by The High
Priestess which of course tracks them
down tries to attack them but given his
age the fact that he's exceedingly old
he's not as strong or as capable as he
used to be and because of the fact that
this girl is so young and she's
inexperienced there's sort of at
opposite ends here right so there's not
really anybody there in the middle that
can easily overpower this Sentinel I
mean Amadeus Cho does to a degree but
it's not without just straining himself
and Things become even more dire when
you suddenly have like like five more of
these Sentinels that show up at of
nowhere and so what they realize is that
they have to find Banner they have to
find Bruce Banner in order to find a way
to either end this threat or at least in
some capacity find a way to save the
world and so where Amadeus Cho is able
to kind of think his way out of the
situation it gives him and this girl a
chance to get away but along the journey
we actually see a couple of cool things
one of the things we see for example is
that it's not just human beings or at
least uh the citizens of this world that
have been exposed to gamma radiation
it's also some of the animals too right
a good example is like this little cat
like animal that's attacked by these
soldiers who are hunting down anything
with gamma radiation and it just like
morphs into like this gigantic Beast
that just massacres all of them and then
leaves
right but much like we would expect when
it came to like Bruce Banner and the
Incredible Hulk it's got its normal form
and then it's hulked out form so it is
kind of cool but the big caveat to all
this and the big question that we're
kind of left asking here is how did all
these things find themselves exposed to
gamma radiation so again again we'll
kind of continue on this journey or
we'll answer that as we continue on with
this but ultimately they end up finding
this kind of makeshift home of Bruce
Banner and they realize that it's his
house because you have Kiera you've got
Korg you've got She-Hulk right pictures
of these guys here the kicker about all
this is that She-Hulk it's a picture of
her when she's on zakar so again there's
a lot of really cool questions that
we'll get answers to don't worry I'm not
gonna leave you guys hanging we'll get
answers to all this stuff but ultimately
Bruce Banner ends up arriving on the
scene now one of the things about this
is that Banner is initially able he
talks to them and he communicates with
them and kind of hears what it is that
they have to say but it's one of those
things where Amadeus Cho introduces this
girl as his granddaughter and when she
says like Bruce Banner we need your help
you know he's like well I'd be happy to
help you and she says we're not talking
talking to you I'm talking to the Hulk
and that's when we get this kind of Old
Man Logan type situation right for those
of you guys who don't know about that in
the Old Man Logan storyline Wolverine
was tricked into killing the X-Men and
as a result of that he refused to pop
his claws if if you want to know any
more about that make sure you check the
playlist down in the description after
this video is over Old Man Logan is a
phenomenal story but the reason why I
say it's an Old Man Logan type situation
is because Bruce Banner almost kind of
refuses to let the Incredible Hulk out
when this girl says like we're here to
talk to the Hulk the Hulk initially
tries to manifest but Bruce Banner won't
let it and he literally Keeps The
Incredible Hulk contained and that's
kind of a cool thing that goes on here
because he says like I'm sorry the Hulk
is not available so for whatever reason
he refuses to become the Incredible Hulk
and so it's kind of funny because they
follow him and literally it's just like
she asks him like like you haven't even
heard what it is that we want to have
done and he says a thousand years ago I
stood with kyera we stared out over the
steps and I said maybe we should just
leave right we should just go we should
just disappear never fight again and she
told me you don't have to fear yourself
and so he says we went back to save the
world you know how that ended right look
at this world that we live on and he
says she died along with thousands of
others gone in an instant when the
crowned city fell and the response to
this girl is that was a long time ago
right right now there's an evil princess
or an evil Priestess rather she's
killing every single Hulk that she finds
except the little kids that she's
kidnapped my brother and the responsive
Banner is that sounds like a you problem
not a me problem and it's it's kind of
funny because he doesn't do this from
the perspective of just kind of
dismissing her he says that it's always
the same generation after generation
it's one of these things where people
don't want to make the world better they
just want to make things worse for the
people that they hate the reality here
is you do not see the Incredible Hulk as
a way to bring peace to this world you
see the Incredible Hulk as a way to
punish the people that you hate and her
response is no like that's not what I'm
looking for I just need the Incredible
Hulk so I can basically save my brother
and it's a really interesting set of
events here because in a lot of ways the
Hulk doesn't want to have anything to do
with this and literally where she says
fine one then we'll just go find the
She-Hulk his response is no right you do
not need to go find She-Hulk so in
effect what we have going on here is the
planet sakar whereby whatever Manner and
whatever means virtually every version
of a Hulk on Earth somehow found their
way here and it's really really cool
it's really interesting because again
it's not something that we've readily
seen before and so that's when this girl
asked the question of Amadeus Cho
where's She-Hulk where's Jennifer
Walters only for us to find out that the
floating city that exists out there that
She-Hulk is the one that's powering it
she's literally hooked up to a machine
and her gamma radiation her energy is
what keeps the city afloat so to a
degree is kind of dystopian honestly it
doesn't really have that kind of
dystopian tone it doesn't feel like Old
Man Logan or anything like that but it
is kind of wild because what we end up
finding out is that She-Hulk was very
much a warrior on sakar right they call
her the sakar child She-Hulk Harga right
like she helped to make the last great
piece but she always knew how to smash
and so it's a really cool thing here
because basically she ended up joining
Banner on sakhar somewhere along the
line here and so as they make their way
towards trying to find She-Hulk they're
again set upon by some more Sentinels
but they're actually safe in these
Sentinels by the timely arrival of cork
who is very much alive here in this this
reality right and so what ends up
happening is cork basically reveals the
reason he's here is because he received
the message that they had when they were
asking for Aid and they were trying to
find She-Hulk and of course what we also
end up finding out is that this girl's
name is tala now her brother's name is
also Balo I'm pretty sure so I mean
their names aren't overly important but
I'm sure some people may have been
wondering by now but it is one of these
little moments where she finally reveals
her name to Cho and in fact Cho actually
asks for it but what you have with the
arrival of Korg is that one Korg knows
who Amadeus Cho is so it's kind of this
feeling that like the gang's all here
more so than that once Amadeus Cho and
this and tala are brought to the
floating City by cork they immediately
seek out She-Hulk and once they come
across Jennifer Walters what we end up
finding out is that she's been hooked up
to this machine for 87 years she's been
here for an incredibly long time now the
other Revelation here is that as far as
she-hulk's concerned she's what's called
an original Hulk and that because of the
gamma radiation in her system and the
nature of her being a Hulk the healing
factor and all that kind of stuff she's
also centuries old she's lived a
thousand years she's been here for an
incredibly or at least been alive for an
incredibly long time more so than that
there is a level of exhaustion that
comes with the fact that her gamma
radiation is constantly powering the
city but of course when Amadeus show
shows up here she kind of asked the
question what brings you here what's
going on and he says A lot's been
happening here and so what she does is
she unplugs herself in the city once all
the information is given to her by
Amadeus Cho and the reason why is
because the various priests and the kind
of religious governing body on this city
has quite literally been lying to
She-Hulk about everything going on on
the surface that she spends all her time
inside this kind of engine room so the
only information she has in terms of
what's going on in the world is whatever
it is that they tell her and the world
has turned into a very dark place now
again I know there's a lot of mystery
here I know there's a lot of questions
that are not being answered yet that you
probably have bear with me we are going
to answer them there is going to be a
tell-all towards the end of all this but
again not every question is going to be
answered so we're going to kind of have
to throw in our own our own perspective
on what we think actually transpired and
so of course with them having She-Hulk
at their side and She-Hulk being
stronger than Amadeus Cho and of course
tala herself they end up bringing her to
where all the young kids are being held
the problem is that this was an ambush
it was literally a giant ruse because
once Amadeus Cho gets in there he
realizes that the the initial assumption
he had that the kids are being
experimented on or something like that
by The High Priestess that all goes out
the window there's no Machinery or
anything they're just being held in a
room that has nothing in it and so
that's when the whole ruse is where The
Jig Is up and we end up finding out it
was a trap the whole thing was to lure
Amadeus Cho along with uh along with
tala and then to basically find a way to
destroy them not only that to try to
find a way to capture She-Hulk and so
what we end up getting is this
explanation of seemingly what had gone
on when it came to Planet Hulk or at
least it came to this story will we end
up finding out here and this is where we
kind of have to inject our own
perspective here that of course the the
original events of Planet Hulk do seem
to have taken place here the Incredible
Hulk was tricked by the Illuminati into
going onto a ship with the intention of
sending him to a peaceful Planet he
passed through a wormhole he ended up on
sakhar which was war-torned he overthrew
the existing government alongside Kaira
and the other members of his warband
Korg and so on and so forth and that
seemed to lead to the events of Planet
Hulk which led to led to basically the
death of Kaira and so on him coming back
to Earth Waging War against the
Illuminati and everything kind of
transpired from there but again there's
nothing to confirm this but there's also
nothing to deny it what seems to have
happened here is that following the
events of the original Planet Hulk and
World War Hulk event and possibly even
the events of like the heart of the
monster Hulk storyline that Bruce Banner
returned to the car except this time he
brought Amadeus Cho and he brought
She-Hulk and that once they arrived here
on this world that what had basically
taken place is that there was a kind of
war that had happened on sakhar
following the the leaving right
following uh the departure of the
Incredible Hulk and his War bound and
that once these different hulks returned
here that basically She-Hulk brokered
peace right between like the third and
fourth uh regimes right the empires
basically and for a Time the world was a
peaceful place but by whatever Manner
and whatever Means War ultimately broke
out yet again this time when war did
break out that you had a high priestess
right she was literally watching
everything that transpired that
specifically she was a shadow priest now
for those of you guys who aren't
familiar with that Cairo was a shadow
priest right they are individuals who
are associated with the old strong
basically the ability to manipulate the
Earth and in fact the the shadow priests
themselves were allies of the Incredible
Hulks and all these folks who were
fighting in this war they were fighting
to save the lives of the Shadow priests
but as this whole event transpired and
as this war unfolded this particular
Shadow priest began to realize what the
hulks were capable of right she
literally says everything I was ever
taught said that there was reason to the
world that what we do matters that each
one of us has a role to play a
particular purpose but against the power
and fury of the hulks nothing matters
ten thousand Imperial soldiers died that
day yes they are my enemies but they
were Flesh and Blood just like me not
monsters like you and so in reality as
flimsy as this plot is the entire basis
of why this High Priestess is going
around and hunting down every Hulk she
can find and killing them is because she
sees them as a clear and present danger
to their their own existence and so
that's it
that's why she's doing all of this and
she literally just wants to kill them
all and there's really nothing more to
it than that and so what ends up
happening is she basically activates a
machine within the core of the world
itself this starts to pull the world of
heart now not everyone knows this and in
fact because she's a high priestess she
is kind of the religious leader of
seemingly everybody on sakhar and so
what ended up happening is she basically
foretold quote unquote the end of the
world as a result of the hearts right
the hulks when in reality this end of
the world that she was preaching about
would be of her own creation it's just
no one would know the truth about what
was going on it would make her look more
important and more powerful than she
actually is now the other part of this
is we end up learning about how events
transpired from The Incredible Hulk's
perspective and what he does is he
basically approaches the statue of Kaira
and he says you brought this world
together when I stood by your side I
thought I could too if you were here now
you'd know how to heal without harm like
you did the first time it all fell of
heart while I raged you focused and
saved our children are beautiful boys
you gave them your old Power so you
could protect them forever as they
Protected Their world now the Incredible
Hulk is referring specifically to scar
as well as hero kala now scar is more
well known if for no other reason than
the fact that we saw that crappy hippie
version at the end of the She-Hulk show
but scar in the comics was amazing he
was a really cool character think of
like everything you saw with scar in the
She-Hulk TV show and imagine like the
complete and total opposite of that and
that's what scar was right literally you
look up the definition of badass in
Marvel Comics you're gonna see a picture
of Scar next to him he's like like uh
like if if Conan became the Incredible
Hulk right just the most amazing thing
ever this guy went toe-to-toe with a
juggernaut at one point in time it was
awesome right scar was so fantastic of
course Scar and all that kind of stuff
is all covered down in The Incredible
Hulk playlist that we have which you'll
also find in the description in addition
to Old Man Logan pick whichever one is
interesting to you hero challah is the
Sun that very few people know about in
uh in the Marvel Comics Community but
he's actually the more powerful between
himself and scarred he actually almost
killed Galactus right hero kala was nuts
in terms of how powerful he was it was
crazy but the reality here is that the
histories of these characters do seem to
be intact right hirokawa had basically
died scar I think is dead I haven't seen
hide nor hair that guy in Marvel Comics
for years like I don't even know if he's
a thing anymore but the important thing
is that the the histories of these
characters do seem to be intact but so
much time has passed that either they're
dead or they're somebody just out there
doing their thing that they're no longer
part of the equation technically
speaking in this comic at the end of the
first issue is a backup story that kind
of focuses on on scar being on Earth but
it doesn't really establish anything he
just kind of feels abandoned by his
father and like that's basically it
right so again we don't really get a
whole lot of information there it's
really kind of a pointless story to be
honest with you but the thing about this
is that with Banner feeling the effects
of the World quite literally being torn
apart and that she-hulks being used to
power this device this literally
destroying the world that what ends up
going on here is that Amadeus Cho ends
up meeting with Bruce Banner albeit
through a kind of computerized device
but what he tells Banner is don't come
here right like do not come to this
location everybody wants the Incredible
Hulk to do it but if he does because of
the fact that Hulk is literally just
this kind of force of Rage that there's
not a whole lot that anybody could do to
stop him if he just blows his lid and
starts destroying everything now that's
one of the big differences between the
original World breaker Hulk and the one
that we see here the original World
breaker Hulk was Far More in control of
himself right far more in control of his
emotions that was perfectly established
by the time you got to the events of
world war Hulk it wasn't just the
Incredible Hulk indiscriminately
smashing everything he could speak
clearly and he was incredibly
intelligent not Professor Hulk level
intelligent but was like more
intelligent than Savage Hulk usually is
this version of The Hulk here doesn't
really seem to have that level of
intelligence right it just kind of seems
to be a raging beast in some ways but
we're actually going to find out that's
not the case that he's every bit as
intelligent as the original World
breaker Hulk that the legacy of him
being this kind of raging rampaging
Beast is more a result of how things
transpire during the different Wars that
took place on sakar as opposed to the
actual nature of himself now of course
Amadeus Cho is able to basically free
Jennifer Walters from the device that's
literally causing the world to break
apart but the problem is that even when
she's freed from this that the damage is
too far done right it's literally just
shaking apart there's really nothing
they can do at this point in time and so
that literally leads to the Incredible
Hulk showing up on the scene now the
kicker to battle the kicker to this
whole thing is that the high priestess
is the one who's ordering all these
different people to go through and kill
every Hulk they can but they've got
they've got reservations about this one
because they're not Warriors they're not
soldiers and two because they weren't
necessarily on board with wiping out all
the hulks just because of the fact that
yes the high priestess is their leader
but while we don't necessarily or at
least we didn't necessarily see what was
going on behind the scenes the illusion
here is that anyone who stood against
the high priestess was summarily
executed right like they were made an
example of so if only out of fear most
people didn't stand against her but the
reality is the legacy of the Hulk is
sure one of like violence and
destruction and rage and all that kind
of stuff but people also remember the
fact that he liberated sakhar from the
power of the red King and that in turn
he did lead a peaceful planet for a
period of time so for in a lot of ways
people's question is why should we be
trying to destroy the Incredible Hulk
right this is Carson why shouldn't we
simply just like Ally ourselves with
this guy right the unification of our of
of all of us is much better off than
like all of us Waging War against each
other on a Dying World and spending our
last moments in like a state of conflict
and so with the war bound basically
reformed albeit with a different roster
than we traditionally saw you've got
Amadeus chohok you've got World breaker
Hulk and you've got She-Hulk who are all
unified together alongside cork the
problem with this is that with this
machine underground and a continually
pulsing and tearing the world apart the
only thing Amadeus Cho can think of as a
way to basically destroy the machine is
to smash it right like it's the only
thing he can think of which is what
world breaker Hulk is best at doing so
he does exactly that right he literally
smashes the machine and it basically
keeps the Earth or keeps the world
protected right it keeps the world from
breaking apart but the other part of
this is Amadeus Cho says the Priestess
machine wasn't just splitting the
surface it was trying to stop the molten
core of the planet from spinning and
that by basically destroying the machine
it stopped the core of the planet right
like at this point the planet will
inevitably just die right I mean this
it's there's seemingly no way to stop it
here and so World breaker Hulk realizing
oh like he's the only one that can
basically save the world jumps into the
core of the planet and when he does so
he basically smash is the planet's core
which sends it back into motion again
right gets the planet's core moving
again and then ultimately Saves the Day
in response to this the world
experiences a reunification right the
realization that the Incredible Hulk is
not nearly as dangerous and terrible as
the high priestess made him out to be
and that under what is in effect the
leadership of the Hulk alongside the
rest of the whole family so cars kind of
led into a peaceful future in terms of
what happens to the high priestess we
don't necessarily know there's no
indication that like she was executed or
anything like that but yeah that's
basically this story I mean it was ass
this story was terrible it was really
really bad but it is the return of the
world breaker Hulk so with that being
said guys
we're gonna we're gonna bring this
travesty of a story to the to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace